[Music]
do you recognize the person you see on
your screen yes he is the great Thomas
Edison do you know what he is known for
in 1879 he invented the first practical
long-lasting electric light bulb and
since then our homes are bright even
after sunset you must be aware of the
fact that lights in our homes work on
electricity however they're not the only
ones that use electricity our
televisions air conditioners water
heaters fans and so on also need
electricity to function laser light or
even small flashlights also work on
electricity imagine a life without
electricity in the world today the
discovery of electricity has helped to
start a new revolution in the history of
humankind but let's just keep aside all
the rhetoric talks and try to understand
the real thing I haven't really told you
what the term electricity means well
there are basically two forms of
electricity one is static electricity
and the other is dynamic electricity for
now we are only interested in dynamic
electricity from the name itself we can
say that it implies moving electricity
or more precisely moving electric
charges now the next question you have
will be what are electric charges the
concept of electric charges is very
important in physics and it cannot be
explained in a video too but I will
still try to give you a short and to the
point explanation of this concept so
let's begin there are two types of
electric charges positive denoted by the
plus sign and negative denoted by the
minus sign think of magnets for a moment
we know that two light poles that is two
North or two South Poles of magnets
repel each other and unlike poles
attract each other similarly like
charges that is to positive or to
negative ones repel each other and
unlike charges that is opposed
and a negative one attract each other
but what exactly is charged or in other
words who actually carries these charges
well these charges are carried by tiny
particles with incredibly small mass
they're called subatomic particles the
positive charges are carried by
particles called protons while negative
ones are carried by particles called
electrons there are billions and
trillions of protons and electrons
present in any object around us in some
objects like metals electrons can move
randomly while in nonmetals their
position is kind of fixed and hence they
cannot move freely now any appliance in
our house for example a tube light works
because the negatively charged electrons
are moving in the wire in one direction
this unidirectional motion of electrons
in a wire is also called electric
current these vias are made of metal
usually copper or aluminium and you can
understand why but why are the charges
in a wire moving in one direction or
what makes the charges move in the wire
the charges move in one direction in the
wires because of the energy supplied to
them by the Transformers so the
transformer supplies energy the charges
move in a wire which in turn makes our
appliances work a flashlight also works
the same way but here the energy is
supplied by the two electric batteries
so to sum it all up dynamic electricity
is flow of electric charges through
conductors like say a copper wire
generally when we talk about electricity
or electric current we mean dynamic
electricity
hence we simply say that electricity is
nothing but the flow of electric charges
through a conductor in the next video we
will learn how to light up a small torch
bulb using a single electric cell so see
you there
[Music]